you're a Sharp Dressed Man you're
talking about growing up in an
environment with a single parent
household I'm assuming that was your mom
not your dad
that's correct so you know you got
secondhand clothes we used to have a
store here in in the city where I live
here in Toronto was called byway I don't
know if it's still around in other parts
of the country or even other parts of
the world but the but the running joke
was you know kids would come up to me in
in school and they'd say oh hey Rich I'd
like those jeans but I couldn't get my
arm down far enough in the byway box to
reach it to pull it out because it was a
uh it was a a clothing donation box
right
um so if I ended up with rips or tears
in my knees that's a dog chewing on a
chew toys give me one second excuse me
excuse me mate please continue yeah so
you know they make fun of you in your
clothing and if you know you ended up
with tears or reps in your jeans you
know my mom would sew up some patches
and you know that's how we did it you
know we didn't have a lot of money
either but
um the significance of that when you're
a child
and then growing into yourself and
becoming a man when you have the
resources like how important is it to
dress a certain way for you today
I mean it's it's such a cool thing that
I view it as more of a symbol of the
fact that I I have you know that poor
kid who was angry at his day-to-day
reality I've changed that so for me it's
beyond just dressing and wanting to look
high status or project value this is me
saying
I was I mean we're all driven by our
belief systems right and the belief
systems that were formed during my
formative years was that I was a poor
kid whoever laughed at and even that
secondhand clothing smell it was a real
like I got teased about it in class so I
think as I was you know those early
years deep in my brain was this strong
Devotion to level up in life and the
clothes are the symbol of that so now
you won't see me rocking a t-shirt or a
hoodie you know like these Tech Bros I
often say if you're going to be a you
know a professional dress like a
professional uh and so it's it's so deep
in me that it's it's it's you know
symbolic of my rise from a poor kid to
someone who isn't poor anymore to answer
your question brother but also just a
quick thing that I often say to a lot of
guys in my circle if you want to do one
thing that brings massive return on
investment let's get to the tailors
learn how to dress well you know find a
tailor that you can work with over the
years the the ROI on that in terms of
projecting value of professionalism also
in dating or just feeling like you're
the man and as Tate often says you know
there's no downside to believing you're
the man it's only really positive right
if you want to really level up in terms
of how you're perceived and how you feel
I do believe that tailored clothing you
know if you get fashion forget what's
trendy go with what's classic that you
know one Navy Blazer and a sharp white
shirt from a tailors can really
transform a young man's
like life in it how he's perceived and
how he feels so I've taken literally
hundreds of my brothers to the sailors
for exactly our reason that's how
important it is yeah and I mean the cost
to get tailored stuff isn't as expensive
as you think it would be I'm sure in
Dubai the you know the quality of the
material and the uh quality of the work
is is going to differ as the other
places uh you know I'll do with the guys
that I use they're actually from Hong
Kong and they come here every four or
five months they rent out a hotel suite
that you know you go in they basically
measure you up and then you know your
shirts come in the mail
two three four weeks later you can get
three shirts for about 300 bucks you can
get really nice shirts for you know a
few hundred dollars more but even like
the standard shirts are well worth it if
if all you can get is just three shirts
just get three shirts you know keep them
on your rack different colors start with
something at least at least with that
because everything that's off the shelf
I don't know if it's like this in Dubai
but here most people are relatively
overweight you know they're obese
morbidly obese somewhere in that realm
so the shirts are very baggy they don't
fit you around the waistline they're
very puffed out
same thing over there
um I mean we don't have the uh the North
America's special in terms of you know
that that mass obesity uh but I what I
would say from personal experience once
you're used to tailored you cannot wear
off the rack you just can't do it
especially for guys like us who have you
know muscularity and body types that are
not gelling with you know the average
dude who likes Netflix in his his
PlayStation
um yeah I I think anything I get off the
rack likely won't fit so it's I haven't
I haven't worn off the rack shirts for
10 years and I I don't think I can go
back I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out